what's going on guys Batman V Superman
spoiler video my buddy John Flickinger
and I AKA the flick pic just saw the
film you've known our thoughts we have
given our thoughts on our separate
channels now it's time to talk in depth
spoiler filled if you haven't seen the
movie go see it then check out this
video let's get started so Chris we've
been waiting three years for this movie
are you long ears very long years man
and it's like so much has happened over
the last three years we've both made
tons of videos talking about Batman V
Superman this is probably besides Star
Wars for you yeah our most anticipated
movie for like the last three years of
making you easily easily I mean I grew
up loving these guys I grew up wearing
Superman like underwear outside my jeans
running around the house I still do
okay well I meant when I was a kid oh
but I still want to yeah yeah it's an
adult I want to yeah and sometimes I do
and you fam you can ask Sam I did that's
I didn't want to bring it up but she did
tell me things so I don't usually drink
alcohol but you know in this case it's
late we've already filmed a lot of
Batman videos and marks are lemonade
isn't like you know hard liquor by the
way not sponsored this is entirely not
sponsored this is just me drinking micro
lemonade after Jesse Eisenberg's
performances Lex Luthor I think alcohol
is required
yeah I could give you that one I can
give it you do not want to fight this
guy mmm
all right where we gonna go with this
overall I thought the movie was a mess
we've already talked about this in
review so let's get into spoilers yeah
doomsday whoo okay so we're gonna start
off there let's just let it just have
little one right there all right I'll
give my take yeah quick uh the build-up
and the motivation of Jesse Eisenberg's
Lex Luthor creating doomsday I get why
he made him sure he hates he's
essentially hates God yeah and Superman
is the closest representation of God and
he won
to destroy that maybe for some self
accreditation or maybe us to prove that
he's better but when they introduced
doomsday by somehow shoehorning in one
of the spaceships from general Zod's
fleet yeah as a generation chamber to
birth creatures
you mentioned the ships narration yeah
did you love how like he walks him and
the ship is like hello and then he has
rather than just cutting off general
Zod's entire hand to use in general
Zod's hand in these fingerprints he very
carefully cut off the finger skin yeah
to place over his own fingers I'm like
just cut off his hand with your
Kryptonian knife and just use the hand
but you know pg-13 or whatever so he
walks in and the computer voice is it's
like hey the what you're doing is
forbidden and you know Kryptonian people
we've we've forbade this for years are
the Kryptonian people still alive no
okay well we're just gonna do it and
then they start making doomsday it was
just it was so convenient really I just
felt very convenient somehow you can
create a human being by putting a corpse
in a pool of urine putting some blood on
his face and somehow that magically
creates a human being by the way why
didn't he need his fingerprints when
general Zod's corpse is right there
beside him like it's like that
that's true that's true like what like
this this is what we're trying to get at
movie has potential and it could have
been easily better but there's so many
lazy script elements it's just like why
did you even do that one of the things
that bug me about Lois Lane was they
struggle to make her relevant after a
while they had the Kryptonian spear she
she grabs it she throws it in the water
for whatever reason I guess she was
trying to get it far away from Superman
then she's like oh I guess they need
that so she dives into the water to get
it then she gets trapped then Superman
has to save her so Superman has to go
down and get the Kryptonite and it's
just like this big back-and-forth with
the writers going how do we make Lois
Lane interesting how do we give her
anything to do besides just being Lois
Lane
she was the damsel in distress
throughout the entire movie she really
was how many things has she fallen off
of the Superman saved her by now it's
basically like her character's
motivation is falling off things
and taking baths and they don't enjoy
that I didn't mind it now before we
continue talking about Amy Adams taking
nice warm soapy baths with a little bit
of bubble going on but we got to get
back to doomsday okay very quickly
because they're just there's too much to
talk about I wanted to mention this very
quickly a few months ago we made a video
we did right here right in this exact
spot your same positioning yeah and we
talked about the trailer and a lot of
people agreed a lot of people disagree
it was very split yeah is it not fair to
say that that trailer essentially did
break down the major plot points of the
movie more than fair the only thing that
it didn't say was it Superman gives his
life yes it's Superman dies and then
essentially goes back to life by the end
of the movie that yeah I know it was
funny because it ended and Superman died
and I was like okay that's ballsy no I
am all with that in my review I said the
film makes a choice that I thought was
brave but then doesn't follow through
with that choice either that was you
know they killed Superman and I was like
good that's ballsy that's like I give
you respect for doing that but then the
little dirt follicles rise so he's alive
I expected that it's hard to have the
Justice League without Superman's but
still I was like Zack Snyder you know
this movie was a mess but you made a
hard choice there and then they couldn't
even end their film following through
with that choice and it kind of bugged
me the trailer 100% spoiled everything
it's basically a summation of the movie
it shows that there's going to be a
fight it shows that the fight outcome is
that they team up and Wonder Woman shows
up and saves them for a second with her
shield and then doomsday is there that
trailer kind of ruined everything I have
no idea how it got approved
I really do her and like I wanted to be
wrong and when we talk about that I
wanted to be wrong about that but when I
was watching the newly unfold I was like
beat for beat they show that they really
did and in all fairness there's a few
little things that happen in between
those major plots but the major plot
points roll there now I have something I
want to talk about okay I want to talk
about Ben Affleck's email to Wonder
Woman oh oh it was like hey I want you
to know that I know who you are and I
like how she like over dramatically
scrolled through it like revealing one
ladies after another was
instant-messaging
yes
email like everyone would just scroll it
and read the entire thing but no since
it's a movie if we get one line at a
time and then of course it's filled with
like files of every major Justice League
character including video surveillance
footage of all of this you get to see
the flash you get to see Aquaman you're
gonna see cyborg and I'm sorry it was
just look this is what the writers came
up with she reads a email that's
it that's the cameos
that's our Justice League set up she
reads an email goes deeper than that
Chris you're forgetting the the little
visually stunning icons somebody
somebody at Lex Corp took the time keep
in mind these are top-secret Lex Corp
files somebody took the time put
together a brain thinking dream team of
designers and they made logos for each
one of these top-secret metahumans the
flash had one aquaman had one cyborg had
one how dumb are you going to treat your
audience that you can't you can just put
the name of the the flash or something
they had to put his logo there to me
just felt like hey we're more concerned
about setting up the Justice League than
making a great film and you could feel
like the first half of the movie was
very grounded very serious it felt very
like political thriller ish there was
brief appearances from superheroes
amongst the political thrills and then
it just became hey there's justice
league and we need to have doomsday we
need to have wonderful men we need to
have all these cameos we need to have
all this setup and it was just this big
mess a hodgepodge of superhero bukkake
that's a good way to what I'm going to
put it I'll drink to that
as you drink to that I want to briefly
talk about some of the the cameo scenes
because I made a video on this a long
time ago
and this was a year ago and it was just
rumored at the time but a few of those
actually panned out to be somewhat
accurate the flash of scene was him
stopping a robbery at a liquor store
okay I I was okay with that cool it is
what it is yeah and then we had Aquaman
and I said this once I was on where all
right no man the way Aquaman was first
presented he comes out of a dark hole in
the ocean he's like and he just like
looks at everyone all magical like and
it looks like he can't even swim it
looked like they
Jason Momoa and a swimming pool in
someone's backyard and film it and then
he shoots off through the water breaking
the sound barrier of water so really
think about this okay you're a
professional writer in Hollywood you are
writing a screenplay your screenplay is
for Batman V Superman and you have her
open an email to introduce us to the
characters of the Justice League and
email that's the easiest thing they
could have done I heard a rumor a long
time ago and we're gonna give some
constructive criticism here okay
I read the rumor a long time ago that
when Batman in the movie he breaks in
and steals the Kryptonite which they
don't even show that scene oh oh maybe
it's in the r-rated I wish they would've
though I know that see we need to talk
more about that that could be I heard
that hey she goes through some lex court
files while he's doing that and that's
how he sees the cameo scenes and that
makes sense because Batman's kind of the
leader of the Justice League he's the
one wants to set the whole thing up so
him having that knowledge would you make
sense by the end of the movie and would
have been a better way to introduce it
let's talk about the fight so to me it
just felt rushed okay not about you and
I know you liked it a little more than
me and I didn't dislike this movie
there's this thing on the internet where
you either have to love it or hate it no
grey zones anymore lover hey can't just
enjoy I'm in the middle of the road yeah
we're talking more about things we
didn't like but you know there were
things we liked we've we've just we've
reviewed it already into the positives
yeah or I mean you know Affleck was
great it was cool to see him punch
things he killed a lot of people which
was kind of up man was a mass
murderer I said this after the movie to
you it was I was like they didn't
definitively show him kill someone it
was always like kind of like a wide shot
of something blowing up near somebody
they never just showed him go like and
the guys go flat there's a lot of dream
sequences where he murders people but
then in real life like you said I think
after the movie he just like mows down
this guy with a machine yeah the during
the car chase scene the guy shoots at
him and he's like you buddy pulls
at his machine gun and the entire car
just blows apart I right before you can
see that that guy's head would explode
by bullet penetration cuts exactly it's
like they never definitively showed him
work but he's obviously murdering people
let's write he has to so I don't get it
and what I said to you always look if
they're gonna have
Batman in this movie kill people at
least acknowledge it have a scene
anything where Alfred maybe approaches
him and is like you know you're going
too far with this he's like well they
they killed Robin they killed all these
people I have nothing left and then it
explained his rage why he changed his
moral code because for me that was the
most interesting thing about Batman was
his the moral code that he had the fact
that he kind of rolled that line of just
barely becoming a criminal but but he
was like right there and so eliminating
that just makes him Punisher with a cowl
on and that kind of disappointed me I
agree the more so focused on Superman
not wanting to kill anyone yeah and then
kind of dropped it for Batman but back
here your one point about kind of just
washing over things and jumping into it
uh they're fine their fight sequence now
like we said there's about 30 minutes
this movie on the editing room floor
somewhere I'm hoping when that blu-ray
comes out there's more build-up to that
that big fight because it's Batman V
Superman yep now I have no complaints
with the fight no I did sorry beautiful
brutal badass enjoyed it yeah let that
build up to that epic fight was the most
half-assed lazy convenient thing in the
entire movie very lush should have been
the most important thing I think we sort
of understand Batman's motivations why
he wants to take out Superman the movie
did its job there but as far as Lex
Luthor being involved and the timing of
it and Batman's timing of wanting to put
this precise fight together you had
Batman he planned this entire situation
out and so did Lex Luthor but how they
never worked together to do this right
but they both plan it at the exact same
time the same day how did that come
about actually never thought of that
that's very true yeah it's all just kind
of happens on one night no no didn't
communicate they were working together
let's River did know Batman's plan I I
never thought of that actually yeah
interesting yeah II just blew my mind
um it does yeah one of the things you
talked about was the fact that uh you
kind of understood why Batman hated
Superman he was there in Metropolis when
all that went down a Man of Steel
people that Batman cared about were
killed that day Superman doesn't really
have a clear motivation for not liking
Batman what is he a vigilante a big
deal like why why do you want to
beat up Batman
yeah I bought it what is Batman done
that's so bad that's affecting you now
if they had this is again about the
Batman killing thing here's a perfect
opportunity to use it for the story have
Superman be like Batman you can't go
around killing everybody I mean yeah I
snapped general Zod's neck but you know
about you it's not like I go around
killing everybody all the time like you
cuz you're Batman and apparently Batman
you just murder people all night
breaking necks
I mean that would have been something
yeah it would have been like hey you you
know stay down man cuz you've been
killing too many people cuz you know you
can't murder but okay again they don't
use it there's so many things they could
have usually and they don't and like you
said there's no real reason for them to
fight they just it's just it's because
the movie is called Batman V Superman so
we expect it to happen I know I did but
I just wanted some reasoning now I think
most people are going to say well the
reason Superman went to fight Batman
because his Lex Luthor kidnapped his
mother but before that Superman had a
problem with Batman throughout the
entire movie exactly for no reason right
right he flies in is like the bat is
dead next time your signals in this guy
don't go to it why it's like you just
stop me from chasing down criminals who
murder people they're right there but
why are you stopping me exactly yeah
it's really crazy what exactly was he
doing just proving that he's Superman I
said suppose yeah but like Batman was
just chasing some criminals and Superman
didn't help
no he just was like hey stop that by
criminals go ahead and go the patch dead
bury it okay so we've been saying a lot
of negatives and we do have some
positives a few but I think my last big
negative before we jump into the good
stuff is the first half of this movie
was very choppy yeah that goes back to
cutting things out possibly because if
they did cut things out of that first
half of that movie then it was just not
a very good movie the first half they go
from scene to scene to scene the scene
to location to location to location they
throw so much stuff at you so quickly
and it feels like transitions are gone
like it just chops so hard to something
else right it just fell like there are
some scenes even little scenes where
somebody like walks or in a corner does
something but then it cuts to something
else they're doing I remember a very
long time ago
watching Watchmen for the first time and
thinking if this guy made a Batman movie
that would be really good yeah and all
the Batmen parcels and all the batman
parts were the best and I knew they
probably would be so it's funny he the
saving grace all the action scenes in
this movie with Batman reminded me the
arkham knight about how he would just
flip around everywhere and just take
down or tality man just rock
bottom's like elbows to the face knives
to people good stuff man I mean he
Batman a brandy he'll stab ya he'll snap
yeah he'll blow you up yeah and I I
heard that the guy who did the
storyboarding for the animated movies
featuring Batman actually did the
storyboarding for this and you can kind
of see it come into action especially
when he had the grappling hook and he
was in the warehouse fighting and he
grabs the the crates and swung them over
his head that was great I like that and
you don't you just like how Batman
actually was a little bit powered up yes
the thing that I loved in this movie the
most was the action yeah all the action
is great it's a really good looking
movie it's also a mostly really well
acted I mean pretty much everyone's
phenomenal in film I Jesse Eisenberg is
kind of yeah he I don't know if it
worked I think maybe the I don't think
it did I don't think so so much I think
it wasn't he went for like the nervous
which OCD and sanity type thing it
didn't really pay off for me
tone it down maybe 40% I did love Batman
showing up at the end it is gel so yeah
that was badass
I enjoyed how surprising it try to work
Arkham in there but Arkham's for the
criminally insane like maybe it doesn't
really matter I just wanted to
nerd out with Arkham in the movie do
they ever show the outside of it you
know that's could be art it could be art
we look to clean to be our pastors my
passion room there are good things in
this movie Jeremy Irons I thought was
fantastic is Alfred yeah I enjoyed him
if you just want to take all the Batman
stuff in this movie take it out and have
it be its own singular movie and maybe
don't make him kill everybody I think
it'd be phenomenal just that so I'm
excited about the prospects of Ben
Affleck as Batman I think it's the best
looking Batman we've ever had best on
screen by far I mean from everything
from the tone to actually what he's
doing on screen and the visuals I mean
that was perfect that was the Dark
Knight Returns brought to the big screen
yeah and he was also an interesting
verse Wayne
he watches for me the most important
part because if you don't
about Bruce Wayne you know who gives a
about Batman so and I love Bruce
Wayne this movie I like to go as a gal
gadot I go gal gadot she was awesome as
Wonder Woman but again kind of rushed it
was just sort of like she was eight
we gotta have her you know cuz she's
she's wonderful but she has to be here
but Lee's Lee kind of flushed her
character out a little bit compared to
those those three-second cameo scenes
she got an email she got an email but
she worked I you know I was always under
the impression gal gadot she's beautiful
beautiful woman I'm not saying she's not
sure but one woman has a physicality to
her gal gadot about 102 pounds uh but
hey my type of chick no but you know
doesn't mean she should be Wonder Woman
but you know what when she was action in
this movie I'm when she jumped out for
the first time saving Superman's ass
good stuff
it was a crowd-pleasing it worked and I
bought it was a crowd-pleasing moment I
totally bought yeah like I said I bought
interest Wonder Woman just felt like her
character was kind of rushed to me it
was kind of like a whole bunch of great
characters but there just wasn't really
like that hungry yeah the real like
powerful reason for them coming together
it was just sort of like here's a big
monster okay so the flashpoint paradox
thing the flash jumps out to tell Bruce
some things yeah but kind of vision that
we thought was a dream but maybe isn't a
dream yeah yeah okay so I can turn to my
mom when I take her to this movie go mom
that's the flashpoint paradox she can go
would it what what does that mean so
it's one of those things were and then
the whole nightmare sequence where
there's like the things flying in the
background and Batman snapping people's
necks looks great what the hell is that
well I what like I love Batman I just it
didn't make sense just didn't
make sense so Bruce Wayne's having the
dream about nightmare version Batman
stabbing people's necks shits flying in
the air it's in the desert yeah but then
he wakes up to the flash coming back in
time so was the flash telling him these
things as he was not sleeping or no it
just didn't really I don't know this
plane it tirana Mia The Wicker Man the
scene where Nicolas Cage is on a dock he
has this nightmare that a girl's
floating in the in the ocean okay and he
wakes up goes ha and then the camera
zooms out and he's holding a dead body
goes oh ha ha ha and then he wakes up
again he goes ha ha ah ha ha ha
just remind me and just reminded me that
like I wanted been happy to go god never
just like that wicked man seen what was
on the bag short or something
hi yeah viva la French
Wow
I liked how both of their mom's names
are Martha and how it affected them in
that way I did yeah cuz I never actually
thought about that and that was really
powerful but again it was just like a
ticking time sequence they literally put
a red digital clock right next to Martha
to just count down the moments it was
like the end of Dark Knight Rises and
the thing is
speaking of Dark Knight Rises yeah there
are Dark Knight Rises elements in this
movie yeah the ticking time sequence
there's a scene where Bruce Wayne kind
of talks with Wonder Woman at this ball
and she's just stolen something yes just
like in Dark Knight Rises where Catwoman
had stolen something and Bruce Wayne's
talking you're kind of seducing her and
I was like that's very similar and I can
tell you after this movie I think were
the things we mentioned that I know a
home I was like well I guess people are
going to like not hate on the dirt and
Rises as much anymore no you can't it's
not fair if you want to compare
narrative to narrative The Dark Knight
Rises is stronger by far every scene
that Batman was in absolutely loved you
know the bat nips were hard it just that
wasn't the only thing no f'n though I
know that but you can't overlook when a
story gets messy and discombobulated
listen guys if any two guys wanted to
give this movie an A+ and scream up to
the heavens it was us it was us I wanted
you and I remember washing the movie in
the theater tonight and just thinking
that could have been better that could
have been better
Batman's perfect I like that
yeah I completely agree some people want
a better story some people want a better
screenplay and sometimes you have to
imagine that there are men and women
creating these things yeah this is
somebody sitting down getting paid
millions and millions of dollars to
figure this out and if the best they can
do is have gal gadot open a
email and look at some videos of these
guys I'm sorry they could have done so
much more with this story with these
characters with the script just because
the tone was pretty spot-on
and it looked visually great I mean
that's what we already knew what we were
gonna get we already knew the film would
look good we already knew that Zack
Snyder was gonna make good action I have
a question for you ask me the question
John pletely serious okay is that drink
right there yes better than granny's
peach tea did you pee in my
drink haha no man okay good and then
just blows up uh real quick
speaking of that great scene granny's
peach ginseng this one we had some great
one-liners too there are some funny
one-liners
but the see were Holly hunters sitting
there at the podium and she's looking
down at a mason jar full of piss that
says granny's peach tea in a reference
to Jesse Eisenberg earlier on in the
movie I got a sense of like eeriness and
an easiness and I thought that was one
of them probably one of the more
entertaining scenes in the movie that
just put me on the edge of my seat
because I good I didn't know what was
going to happen out of that it was good
I was definitely one of the better
scenes in the movie there wasn't
anything in the movie that I just
outright hated it's just a mixed bag and
like you said the gray area thing it's
it's tough to be in a gray area now it's
with these big movies yeah if I said
that uh mrs. Peregrine school for
peculiar children or whatever that
movie's coming out soon as was okay no
one would care
no but if I said it Batman V Superman is
okay well then it's a problem so I don't
know it's just that there's this a gray
area with this movie it wasn't perfect
but it wasn't bad it wasn't great but it
wasn't awful it was just kind of in the
middle for me for me I I agree for the
most part I feel like there's a lot of
missed opportunities where they got it
wrong they really got it wrong but where
they got it right they got it right sure
and I said this in my review the Zack
Snyder they just set out to make a
direct adaptation of The Dark Knight
Returns and really focus on that rather
than setting up the building blocks for
the entire DC Justice League universe it
would've been a really really good movie
Deadpool was amazing because it didn't
have to set up Deadpool to there's like
two seconds when they say at the end
credits scene by the way we might have
cable money well that's it all the best
superhero movies are movies that are
just movies on their own that aren't as
concerned about setting up a universe or
a world and speaking of movies that came
out the last couple years what's the
last movie that focused a little too
much on setting up the universe age of
Ultron age of Ultron and they both share
the same issues yeah they're messy yeah
they're messy movies well the sad truth
is it is exactly what we expect it
really is
we're judging by the trailers I don't
know how she could have expected
anything else
and I guess overall when it comes down
to it I was entertained for the most
part and I do want to see the movie
again guys
that's our spoiler review of Batman V
Superman again don't hate the movie we
just think it could have been better
we'd like to see a better movie like
this and hopefully Justice League is
going to be better what are your
thoughts let us know below subscribe my
buddy to flick pick.i thanks man he's
awesome he deserves your views thanks so
much as always for watching guys and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck my next